boulet kept podcast man we got the homie
j stone in here
welcome what's up what's up what's up
man what's up kev
hey yo we chillin man listen your new
album uh the definition of pain
is uh is is well look what's today
this is gonna release when this the
album is out all right so the album is
out
um a great body of work man you know i
got to appreciate you sending it over
early so i could tap in with it man
definitely a
very personal project i feel like um
obviously with the title man kind of
give us a little
window into your thought process behind
naming the album
what you named it i mean you know um
you know nit really gave it these titles
you know what i'm saying
with the definition of loyalty yeah you
know what i'm saying you know i let them
hear a lot of songs and [ __ ] before i
even dropped the definition of loyalty
and bro is like man just based on the
stories and
you know what i'm saying you're giving
the g codes on [ __ ] and you know what
i'm saying like man your album should be
called the definition of loyalty you
know what i'm saying because what i'm
getting from these records is like
loyalty
right right [ __ ] like that you feel me
and he like man your next album should
be
the definition of of something else no
i'm saying
pain sacrifice success you know what i'm
saying i just got to start
thinking about all that [ __ ] and i'm
like that's a [ __ ] life right there
though if you think about it